c'est une affaire qui pourrait bien
plonger bruxelles dans l'embarras stella
kyriakidou commissaire européenne
chargée de la santé est soupçonné de
corruption passive
un rapport de la cour des comptes
chypriote son pays d'origine
pointent du doigt l'absence de
justification au tour de près de 4
millions d'euros reçus par son mari
entre 2009 et 2017 et qu'il n'a jamais
remboursé les prêts ont été accordés par
la deuxième plus grande banque de chypre
propriété de l'état la cyprus
coopérative banques confrontées à de
graves problèmes financiers
nécessitant plusieurs renflouements par
de l'argent public
la cour des comptes considère qu'il
s'agit de transactions très
problématique
pourquoi parce que kyriacos kyriacou
d'où ne disposerait pas de garanties
suffisantes en termes de revenus ou de
patrimoine pour obtenir des prêts d'une
telle importance
ce rapport sert à fournir des faits et
non à porter des jugements politiques
chaque citoyen peut se forger sa propre
opinion sur la légitimité ou non de
telles transactions
reste que les soupçons sont alimentés
par leur oubli
si on peut dire de stella kyriakidou fou
dans sa déclaration de transparence au
parlement européen chypriote n'a en
effet pas mentionné la fonction de
directeur de marc alaux limited exercée
par son mari c'est pourtant au nom de
cette entreprise qu'il a reçu les
différents prêts elle n'a pas non plus
précisé
les autres activités de son mari qui est
directeur ou président de pas moins de
neuf sociétés au total
et si pour l'heure madame kyriakidou
assure n'avoir je cite aucune
implication personnelle dans la
polémique entourant son mari c ommission
fait sortir de sa réserve
un eurodéputé allemand la commissaire
européenne à la santé kyriakidou doit
clarifier cela de toute urgence
son mari est soupçonné de corruption à
chypre et la société de son mari est
absent de la déclaration de transparence
de kyriakidou des questions auxquelles
il faut répondre rapidement
s'agit-il d'une affaire de corruption
passive
ce que l'on sait en tout cas c'est
qu'elle est assez embarrassante pour
celle qui est en première ligne sur la
question des achats de vaccins par l'uae
on se souvient que ses commandes de
l'union avait beaucoup fait jaser
notamment à cause du secret qui a
entouré les négociations sur les prix
mais aussi les conditions d'octroi
on peut néanmoins souligné que ces prêts
contractés par son époux à chypre
l'entêté avant qu'elle ne prenne ses
fonctions à la commission en décembre
2019 et donc avant la crise du
coronavirus si ce scandale de corruption
est avérée et pourrait néanmoins
entachée encore davantage la crédibilité
d'une commission européenne de plus en
plus contesté